today I learned that when observed
globally weather station records show an
increase in average daily temperatures
of over half a degree Celsius each
decade since the 1970s I'm reto Meier
Google developer advocate join me as we
explore the NOAA weather data sets with
bigquery climate science can be a
controversial topic so when we told
Savio Lawrence we were putting his
analysis on YouTube he asked us to
preserve his anonymity you just told
them my name am I in this shot it'll
it'll be fine we'll fix it in post so
tell us how did you go about performing
your analysis so I found the weather
data already present in bigquery's
public data set project then I used to
create products bakery and tableau
together beaker includes two weather
station data sets the global summary of
data jihad and global historical
climatological Network ghcn basically
anyone can add data to jihad while GSC
and observations are subjected a common
suit of QA reviews I prepped and
connected this bigquery data sources to
tableau for visualization and analysis
the first thing I noticed was a trend of
increasing average temperatures each
decade for both data set which led to
further analysis climate science is
complicated so let's dive into the
details of this analysis many variables
can influence our results our data sets
are particularly susceptible to bias
from the number of stations reporting
their relative locations and the
frequency of their observations for our
analysis to be meaningful we start in
1973 the year after which there aren't
big jumps in the number of reporting
stations and there's a reasonable global
coverage of stations our averages
include every station with at least 300
measurements in a given year to avoid
seasonal bias this still only tells us
part of the story global temperature
isn't consistent some places it may have
gotten warmer and others cooler the
distribution of reporting station shows
us that there are more stations in the
most heavily populated latitudes as a
result the regions with most stations
will have a disproportionate influence
on the overall climate trends to begin
to account for this we can break our
analysis into smallest
classes of the data based on latitude
bands stations here in the Arctic Circle
show a significant increase in average
temperature each decade one point two
three degrees Celsius per decade for G
sod and point six seven degrees Celsius
the ghcn the northern temperate zone
includes the largest number of stations
and represents the most highly populated
zone as with the Arctic Circle both the
G side and ghcn datasets show a gradual
increase in the average temperature with
0.68 and point six five increases
respectively when we reach the tropics
things get interesting
these graphs show that the average
temperature has remained fairly constant
across both datasets with an average
increase of 0.3 1 and point 2 8 per
decade in the northern tropics and just
0.1 9 and point 2 8 in the southern
tropics once we hit the southern
temperate zone both datasets are a small
but gradual decrease each decade until
now record temperatures in 2015 and 2016
have largely erased the drop since the
1970s are the last two years outliers or
the beginning of a new warming trend for
the southern temperate zone it's too
early to say based on only two data
points but it's an observation worth
tracking finally we reach the Antarctic
where the number of stations is
extremely low compared to the other
latitude bands which creates a noisier
dataset the measurements we do have
indicate a significant cooling trend
each decade one possible influence could
be the increase in reporting stations
closer to the South Pole that have a
lower temperature than those located
further out we can try to unwrap this by
further segmenting the Antarctic Circle
but for now we'll add up to the list of
observations that need more follow-up
when measuring something is complex as
climate change it's important to
remember that there are many variables
that can influence and bias our results
so while making observations is easy
during conclusions isn't analyzing raw
data like this can provide useful
starting points to form hypotheses and
begin further investigations into the
broader trends and potential causes that
they may represent as always your first
terabyte of processing each month is
free so I invite you to open up your
query and do your own analyses and share
results with us and as always subscribe
to our channel and follow our blog to
learn something new every week with
bigquery you know I think it's ok if you
just tell people who I am I don't think
this is that controversial you right
plus we're safe here in the bunker
seriously we have a bunker wait what
thanks for watching click here to
subscribe and be sure to check out some
other videos here